all right so how omiks works in our
lives across many niches and specialties
more than we can list machine learning
is a current hot topic and one we can
always hear about in movies
right we all know about the machine
learning thing well one important trend
we've seen over the past few years is
multi-omics the basic idea is simple
we see different platforms and patterns
in genomics transcriptomics or
epigenomics
are these different patterns describing
one complex biological famine
phenomenon and if so what does the
combination of these signatures in
various omics data mean together
how we integrate the various features do
we just use a database to connect
mutations in a gene with expression
levels in the same gene or is it more
complex than that
so our next speaker nikolae oskalov has
a phd in soft matter theoretical physics
and statistical physics
in 2016 he joined mbis which is the
national bioinformatics
infrastructure in sweden as part of a
bioinformatics long-term support team
nicolet has extensive experience working
with genomics with more acronyms and
exhaustive subject matter areas of
interest and i have time to list right
now
and uh he's also got some programming
experience just to throw it in in case
you need some uh software languages
written he'll be talking mostly about
the integrated integration of biomedical
data but also has research interests
including single cell genomics and
evolutionary research nikolay i can't
wait to hear what you're going to be
speaking on today the floor is yours
hi hi everyone thank you very much grant
for this wonderful introduction
um i'm going to share my screen and i
hope you guys can see it
otherwise please let me know
yes so hello everyone um
i am really really excited to to be at
the symposium
and it's a very very nice
uh to meet all of you guys virtually
um
my name is nicolas kolkov i'm a
bioinformatician from lund university in
sweden and i'm also
employed by an organization which is
called uh scilife labs which stands for
science for life laboratory and i belong
to the uh um
bioinformatics platform of science lab
which is called envis another acronym
the national bioinformatics
infrastructure sweden
and today
i'm going to
share our experience
working with
multi-omics
data integration
from a machine learning point of view so
i emphasize specifically that
we are going to look at data integration
from machine learning perspective
because it's it's uh it's uh this is how
we do it it's not the only way to do it
there are different ways um but i i i'm
going to share
our experience uh that
established now a team
in the national bioinformatics
infrastructure screen i hope it will be
interesting
and informative for you
um
yes so uh this
project this
idea um we started talking about it
a few years ago
maybe around 2015 2016
because many labs in sweden many
academic institutions in sweden realized
that they had plenty of
heterogeneous biological data
and there was a
and there was an idea whether we can
combine somehow those different
biological data types to put them
together to maybe discover somehow new
biology
so it was awake fuzzy idea
at that time
not so many people knew how exactly do
it
what are we going to do but since then i
think we
grew a lot
in our understanding
and we even
now
teaching a course
on uh biological data integration
i believe uh a link to the course
material will be shared with all the
participants
um
and
so what i'm going to present here it's
it's an introduction
uh on
how we uh what what exactly we
understand by by data integration
uh and how we evaluate it so i i will
introduce a few concepts
without going too much into the
methodological details
so first of all
some terminology
i'm going to talk about particular type
of data integration
it's called vertical integration
indeed there are
there is a little bit of confusion here
so some people
introduce the terminology horizontal
integration um and there is a concept of
vertical integration
and those two concepts were nicely uh
explained
in a paper of ricartar galago
and colleagues from oliver stegler uh
lab uh in
in the university of cambridge in the uk
last year um
so
basically they
they
explained in this paper that there is a
horizontal
integration when you work within one
ohmic within one data type and you
simply
combine
statistical observations from
different uh different samples different
cells different individuals
uh different labs um but you you work
within the same uh the same omnic for
example gene expression so you have 20
000 protein coding genes
uh their names are the same you are just
collecting
samples from the u.s from sweden maybe
from asia
and so that's that's one type of
integration it's called a horizontal
type of integration
um i will not be talking about this type
of integration because it's a
sort of uh it's a known uh
problem
uh in bioinformatics uh
which is called the batch effect
correction so if you uh worked with
for example gene expression data
methylation data
or metabolomics maybe you you definitely
know about this problem that it you have
to harmonize somehow uh your your data
to
uh to to basically to combine to combine
um uh data sets from coming from
different labs
so i i'm going to focus on on the
vertical uh integration
because here we have a conceptual
difficulty i would argue that horizontal
integration it's a sort of it is a
challenge
but people worked a lot
in this area and we made a lot of
progress so we have a pretty good
understanding
of how to do it
uh while with vertical data integration
uh here we are working um we are
collecting
multiple layers of biological
information
for the same biological cells
samples individuals
so maybe we are collecting uh
epigenetic information genomics
and transcriptomics uh taken from the
same biological cells
so how to combine
these different data types
so there is conceptual challenge here
what exactly we mean here what exactly
how exactly we are going to do it
and
inside that before we start talking
about
integration
uh more specifically
uh we have to realize one important
challenge
of working with any basically to my
experience any biological
data
uh it's important to to realize that
biological data is high dimensional very
often
and what does it mean high dimensional
um
i'm doing analysis so i'm i'm i'm an
analyst uh so for me uh biological data
it's a multi-dimensional array or
a matrix simply put
and the matrix has uh two dimensions the
dimension of uh statistical observation
and
uh so this dimension uh can be uh so
it's basically just your your samples
cells
uh maybe nucleotides
so it's uh
pictures if you are working with
microscopy imaging
and the second dimension is a dimension
is a p dimension
uh so here uh you
you you're measuring uh certain
variables in your experiment it can be
maybe genes
it can be proteins maybe cpg sites if
you're working with mutilation
um and you are measuring uh
maybe mutilation of a cpg site for one
cell second cell third cell etc
uh so those are your statistical
observation but you uh but the dimension
of features uh those are your cpg sites
and you can
think about this uh metrics
as
um of um n
data points leaving in p dimensional
space
so this p dimension the dimensional
features
it actually uh
builds uh it
builds the the
the dimensionality of
where your statistical observations live
so you have p dimensions and there are n
data points living in this
dimensional space
and
the thing is that in order to do a
robust statistical analysis
you have to
sample this p dimensional space really
well
otherwise you do not satisfy assumptions
of of your of your statistical analysis
so you actually would like to have
the number of data points n to be much
greater than p
but
in reality we have the opposite limit
uh in reality our biological data are
almost always uh have this
dimensionality p much greater than n so
if talking about maybe rna-seq
you have 20 000 protein coding genes
and how many statistical observations
you have how many samples if if it's not
single cell genomics i would argue that
maybe you have hundred samples 1 000
samples maybe
but not
not 20 000 really so you actually are
working on this
p much greater than n
uh limit
the set
said thing is that
um when you combine different data types
when you combine biological uh
ohmics uh you actually uh
as i said you you're doing this vertical
integration so you keep n the same
uh but you're increasing p uh so maybe
uh p1 corresponds to
genes so it's a gene expression so the
first matrix can be gene expression and
the second matrix is mutilation
measured for the same biological
cells
so
same biological cells means that n is
the same but p
is actually in increasing now when you
put two data types together uh because
you you have 20 000 genes and then you
you you add a few millions of cpg sites
so you actually uh your even
your your your uh merged
data becomes even more high-dimensional
and why is it bad well it's a it's a
problem because of the thing which is
called the course of dimensionality
now what is the curse of dimensionality
so we are talking about robustness of
statistical analysis for for data
integration
and
so by statistical analysis you can mean
different things
people
sometimes think about traditional
frequency statistics with p values
hypothesis tests and power calculations
but but there are also
other approaches
to the statistical analysis such as
basin statistics
or machine learning and deep learning
and the choice of statistical method
it actually
[Music]
it it's it's actually
defined by by the dimensionality of your
data
so it's very much about uh whether p is
greater than n or n is greater than p
and uh
uh
so if you're working with this high
dimensional limit as i said uh p much
greater than n that's a typical limit uh
for
uh biological and biomedical data
um
you uh sort of uh sometimes people
do
traditional frequency statistics
i would rather recommend to to to do it
in a basin way
because of sort of
different assumptions
but what can happen
uh
if you
if you have this high dimensional
biological data and you continue with
naive
sort of frequentist
statistics analysis
so here i just give you one example uh
of manifestation of the curse of
dimensionality
uh there are there are
multiple examples but
that's probably most
obvious
so this is a
typical
problem in uh
in
typical frequency statistics analysis
it's called linear regression
when you have a linear dependence
between your data
uh x matrix and your phenotype of
interest more for example if you think
about differential gene expression or if
you're thinking about
uh genome-wide association studies uh
this is essentially what you're solving
uh you're solving this problem a linear
regression problem
uh and this this uh regression problem
can be uh solved in a closed form
uh in this way um and uh basically what
you see here uh in the middle this is
so-called inverse variance covariance
matrix and it can be shown
that in this limit in the high
dimensional limit so remember your
biological data are high dimensional and
if you do data integration you even you
increase the dimensionality of your data
even more
uh so it can be shown that in this high
dimensional limit
uh basically you can't inverse uh you
can't compute this inverse variance
covariance matrix you get into
singularities
um and
so that's a manifestation of the curse
of dimensionality so basically you you
have to always uh remember uh uh about
this this pitfall when you do data
integration you have to watch
for four dimensionalities of your of
your data sets
so that was a warning uh uh fortunately
uh we have a we have an area in life
sciences uh where the curse of
dimensionality is sort of less of a
problem
and this is single cell genomics and a
few years ago
it became
sort of
obvious that
technology single cell genomics
technologies such as 10x genomics uh can
uh leverage uh
hundreds of thousands of cells and even
millions of cells so at that time a few
years ago we'll be talking about one
million cells
then very quickly people started working
was two million cells five million cells
so we are talking about five million
statistical observation
so here we are into the opposite
actually limit uh where you have n much
greater than p
so in in for single cell genomics this
cursive dimensionality less of a problem
but if you are doing data integration uh
using bulk uh sequencing next generation
sequencing data you definitely would
like to uh
keep in mind the dimensions of your of
your data matrices
and avoid this pitfall avoid the curse
of dimensionality pitfall
yes and uh in uh single cell um genomics
uh there are more and more technologies
popping up basically every day that can
deliver so-called multi-modal uh data uh
meaning that you you
can measure
uh multiple uh biological uh types of
information from the same uh from the
same cells
so here at least a few of them such as
scnmt site sig the the recent one was
the
10x genomics multi-ohm really high
throughput technology delivering
a toxic
open chromatin region information and
gene expression information from the
same biological cells
so it's really exciting uh the
development and that's why there is a
lot of methodological development in
this area uh regarding data integration
uh so now i will formally introduce of
what exactly we mean
by omix integration and how we evaluate
whether it worked out whether the
integration worked out
so what what exactly i mean by omix
integration so uh it can be illustrated
with this simple cartoon
um
what you see on this plot that's a
number of uh statistical observations a
number of data points
maybe cells or samples or individuals
one point is maybe one individual and
these individuals or samples they belong
to three different classes
and imagine that you have uh you you
measured two types of biological
information
uh from the same
cells or samples
maybe
you have two omics so your omic one
maybe rna-seq
gene expression information and your
ohmic 2 may be mutilation let's take
mutilation
and uh
so basically what i'm plotting here is
that
um so imagine that you take your gene
expression matrix and you perform a
principal component analysis you do some
dimensionality reduction of your data
and you take just first leading
principal component and you plot it as
x-axis here and then you take mutilation
data you perform
principal component analysis on on your
mutilation data you take pc1 your your
top leading principal component from the
mutilation data and you plot it uh as
y-axis
uh so for both types of biological
information they are available so
mutilation and gene expression they are
available for the same cells for the
same samples
uh
so in case um
in case there is some sort of
so
now imagine that you you project
uh your data points
uh onto the x-axis
and try to uh uh try to separate those
three classes the the black uh red and
green points
so they are very well mixed there is no
way to
separate them
using just one ohmic the same is valid
if you project your data points on the
on the y axis
they are very well mixed uh and they
can't be separated
uh on the other hand if you now put
those two omics against each other if
you plot uh your your data points that
the way i plotted them here
you can see that you can almost linearly
separate those three classes the data
points belonging to three classes
and this is a beauty of data integration
you start discovering
uh some new uh new clustering
new new patterns in the data uh that
were not visible these patterns were not
visible for
individual orgs but they become visible
uh once you once you combine your data i
hope that's a clear what i mean here
so the idea is to see patterns hidden in
individual ownings
and
so that's all can be
done
providing you have some sort of
covariation between your omics so there
should be some link some some sort of
connection
uh between your gene expression in this
case and mutilation there should be some
correlation and there is a nice tool uh
it's called move which we are sort of
teaching our participants of our course
um
that can visualize how well your
different data types are connected uh
correlated so here there are uh sort of
this heat map on the bottom it
demonstrates um it highlights a sort of
linkage uh between three different data
types single cell bisulfite segmentation
data single cell ataxic
open chromatin region uh data and single
cell rna
for the same uh biological cells and so
these colors here mean that uh you
basically so the idea behind this morphe
it's a factor analysis so that you split
your data into so-called orthogonal
latent factors and it turns out that
within the first latent factor you
observe a connection uh between single
cell ataxic and single cell rna6 so
those colors here
uh they
they mean that there is some some
covariance some correlation between
ataxic and rna-seq
and uh bisulfite sick and rna-seq
they're connected they're linked in the
second uh
in the second factor
so that's a way to have a quick overview
of whether
we can proceed with data integration
whether it makes sense whether we have
something in common uh between different
biological data types
so that was about uh what what i mean
exactly by by by data integration it's
sort of a
um
an ability to see something new some new
biology some patterns that were not
visible in individual omics
and now how i evaluate whether
so if suppose i i performed some
integrative analysis so how do i know
that it was successful
and the way we do it here we are looking
uh we are using the concept of
prediction
uh so we are looking at um a boost
a boost in predictive uh capacity so uh
let me explain this a little bit better
so imagine that you have uh three uh
different omics mutilation gene
expression and maybe some phenotypic
morphology data
uh for the same biological cells
and these three different data types
they they have very different
statistical distributions so it would be
very naive just you know to concatenate
those three data matrices without taking
into account the difference in in the
underlying statistical distributions of
the data
um
that's why we need integration proper
integration
and here in the parentheses here in the
parenthesis i uh sort of visualize some
accuracy
of uh predicting uh something about the
cells or samples that's just a cartoon
so the numbers here are made up just for
illustration
uh if maybe we want to to know whether
the samples uh the
cells they came from from their good
cells or bad cells
um and we compute an accuracy of
predicting whether it's a good cell or
bad cell
for each individual ohmic and we achieve
this kind of accuracy
displayed in the parenthesis for each
individual ohmic
now what we want to see when we we've
done data integration is that
the accuracy of classification
uh
or whether it's a good cell or bad cell
whether it's a sick individual or
healthy individual we want to see that
that
data integration accuracy increased the
there was a boost
uh in in the accuracy of uh
prediction and this is actually why i'm
saying that i'm explaining this
[Music]
data integration concepts from machine
learning point of view because
prediction it's a sort of very very uh
very very
important concept uh in machine learning
now how how exactly put these three
different data types together uh they
here we have to dive into the
methodology there are different ways so
we're explaining all these uh different
uh types of data integration uh in our
course
um uh briefly speaking uh there are
three directions
uh first is a uh you have to you you can
convert your data to some common space
where the the data
uh kind of forgets about uh
technological differences so you convert
them to some common space where it's
safe to just concatenate those data
matrices and this is maybe neural
networks similarity network fusion or
umap
can do this very easily
second way is to explicitly model data
distributions and this is typical for
all bayesian uh ways of data integration
so if you have different uh
shapes of data distributions and you can
model
them you you have some idea what was the
underlying data distribution uh then you
can sort of combine uh these different
data distributions uh in a base rule so
if you if you know if you're familiar
with bayes rule that's basically joined
probability of observing all your
different data types so you multiply
sort of your
different data types and combine them as
a base rule and then more for what i
mentioned previously bayesian networks
they're great at sort of uh integrating
uh data through uh through explicit
modeling of their distributions
and then uh the third way is uh sort of
extracting common variation so you don't
really account for for difference in
data distribution but you sort of you
you you factorize your data extract
common variation and factorize it uh and
uh um sort of try to learn uh something
uh some some common factors common uh
excess of variation uh between the
different data types
so i'm not explaining here details i'm
sorry um because and then it will take
more time but but you're very welcome to
sort of come back to me if you want to
know more
and as i said uh so here i'm talking uh
about data integration uh using this
machine learning mentality
uh and
maybe it's it's it's useful to sort of
emphasize uh uh
why i'm sort of uh
talking about machine learning here is
because of the prediction so i as i said
we are using prediction as an ultimate
criterion of successful uh data
integration and that's very different
actually from traditional uh statistical
approaches
uh i would say that's my opinion it's
not written in in stone
but i believe
uh that if you sort of work and if you
do traditional
statistical analysis you are maybe
mostly interested in
detecting candidates some drivers of
your biological process
uh maybe if you are thinking about sort
of genome-wide association studies this
is a manhattan plot
uh where you can sort of detect genes
that have something to do with type 2
diabetes but those are separate genes
it's it's because you're you're testing
them one by one
and the the consequence the consequence
of this uh uh
this type of analysis this traditional
uh statistical analysis that you
sometimes can end up with with a lack of
prediction uh
uh
for for genetic studies this is called
the case of
the of the misinheritability maybe
you're familiar with this
if you if you
have experience in genetics uh that's a
very well known problem there and it
literally means
that genes delivered in this way so you
can get a list of genes that should have
something to do with type 2 diabetes but
if you bring these genes to the clinics
you can't predict you can't use this
genetic signature in order to take a
blood sample from an individual and uh
predict
uh the inclination um the risk of this
individual for type 2 diabetes it
doesn't work unfortunately because of
this
the case of
misinheritability problem which means
the lack of prediction so
um
and in machine learning you optimize
prediction from the very beginning
uh so
maybe you're familiar with this paper uh
where um
was a very famous paper a few years ago
where
uh people sort of uh demonstrated how
so neural networks can be uh can be used
for making very
valuable clinical predictions so really
really bringing
machine learning to the clinics
and
as i said you here here following this
machine learning mentality you you
really start uh optimizing prediction
from the very beginning and in in
statistics statistical approach you are
not really
uh interested in prediction so to say uh
in the beginning so that i hope i i
delivered my message
about the difference in the approaches
and by the way uh even if you start uh
with prediction in machine learning way
uh you still can uh
have a look at the drivers
you can sort of roll it back
and
explain why
why your model can predict so if your
model can predict you you still can
understand uh what are the genes uh what
are the drivers uh that provide this
this good prediction
um but but this is uh delivered by
machine model as a byproduct as i said
um
you from the beginning you start with
prediction and then you can of course
try to interpret it and try to
uh take a closer look why your model can
predict
so now very quickly i i i'll give you um
a practical example so this was a theory
this was sort of uh what essentially we
are doing in many many many different
integrative omics methods
uh now just give you one quick example
how well it works in reality
so here i'm using a multi-modal single
cell uh technology which is called sc
nmt sec it's one of the early uh
multi-modal technologies that delivers
rna-seq biocells and a toxic
for the same biological cells
and as i said it's quite naive to sort
of just merge just concatenate these
data mattresses
and uh one way to overcome this problem
of different statistical distributions
of the data
uh would be to uh as i mentioned
previously to convert this data to some
common space which can be done through
graphs
uh so you you simply uh
now one point here is is one cell
and you are simply so the edges here
they simply mean uh connections
correlations uh between cells
uh so here regardless of the initial
data distribution uh you kind of you
convert your data
uh to some non-parametric uh
representation where the the graphs they
actually don't remember
uh they don't know anything about the
technology that produce the data uh but
once you convert your data into graphs
you you only keep the pairwise
connections pairwise correlations uh
pairwise links uh between your cells so
now once once you converted your
data uh into graphs now you can uh sort
of use a concept which is called graph
intersection
uh so it's demonstrated here
on the left bottom corner so when you
intersect graphs you simply uh keep
edges that are consistently present in
all omics
so looking at these three graphs you can
say that those two cells so it's
highlighted by red the edge between
these cells is highlighted by red so
these cells were connected here in a
single cell rna-seq and they were
connected in single cell bisulfite check
and they were connected in single cell
ataxic so they will be present uh uh on
the consensus graph
so by by doing this graph intersection
you build the consensus graph and
sometimes uh you can you can actually
see new clusters when you combine gene
expression with a genetic
uh so this this is uh if you if you want
to build the the graphs manually but you
don't have to do it actually because
there is a great 2u map and usually
people use umap for for visualization of
high dimensional data
but you can also use it for data
integration because essentially on the
first step of umap you convert your data
into graphs and then there is a one just
line of code you can use uh to overlap
different graphs
and here i'm demonstrating it for for
technology single cell technology
multi-modal technology which is called
side sick which is sort of uh rna-seq
and protein-level information from the
same biological cells
and this how it looks like if you uh
sort of overlap uh this uh two different
umap plots
uh sometimes you can see uh that this
purple cluster here it becomes more
transparent so here it was sort of
smeared out and
was not really detectable for clustering
algorithm but combining gene expression
with protein level information you can
you start seeing new
uh cell type and uh perhaps this is this
cell type has new functionality so gene
expression does not always um
separate uh functionally different cells
gene expression alone might not be
enough to sort of discriminate between
cells
with different functionalities
so i hope
uh that's a little bit clear and here i
would like to wrap it up and um thank
you for your attention this is our team
the national bioinformatics
infrastructure sweden and i'm from lund
university uh
really i really thank you for for
listening
thanks
grant
can you hear me
oh maybe you can hear me now better can
you hear me now yes
all right very good yeah the old
microphone off trick thank you nicolet
that was uh fascinating and thank you
for helping us understand multi-omics
data integration and the challenges that
are being addressed in this way
it uh to me it sounds incredibly
complicated but i know there's out there
others out there that know it better
it's also interesting at the same time
fascinating i'm sure that many of you
are working how specialized and trained
do you need to be in order to use these
complex methods
um
is the question
yes so i mean how specialized do you
need to be able to use these complex
methods is it pretty deep
uh yeah so bioinformatics uh sort of
implies some mathematical training some
fair
understanding of mathematics and
programming i would say
uh so i
would say
that yes and so uh biology plus
mathematics plus program and this is
pretty much what what
builds a good bioinformatician uh
and um
so it depends on the type of analysis
you are doing sometimes you need to be a
better
biologist sometimes you need to be a
better programmer
but what i was explaining so since i
have a mathematical background i see the
data in this way
and i hope you you can also find it
informative for you for your research
very good i think a lot of the people on
the call like to know that kind of stuff
so that gives us a nice background thank
you again we appreciate your time thank
you thank you very much